I'm a wolf raised to be the Alpha trying  to follow alas the Beast can't be tamed  that easily this wild territory is the  perfect den for my kind a free world  where I can roam explore with no end but  I came here on the hunt hidden among  sheep focused on their superficial  dreams moving up the food chain step by  step before I dominate them all one  target always clearly in my sights to  secure the future with technology others  developed but were too fearful to before  but do think law I took this island and  by tooth and claw I will rule it  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  the wolf knows when a predator nears can  a ghost take on the lone wolf  maybe track analyzing stalking patiently  tirelessly but there is no place for the  weak and the wounded here  [Applause]  we are wolves stand boy okay standing by  the position  [Music]  [Applause]  pre-order now for guaranteed beta access  you